when I first started trying to write you
know I expect a matte writing as an
actor and you realized very quickly that
there's a big difference between being
ambiguous and being vague and being
vague is out-of-focus blurry oh yeah
everything's kind of true and being
ambiguous is a little bit more like a
Zen koan you know you're ringing a bell
towards a larger truth and you're
guiding an audience to think for
themselves rather than dictating an
answer that to me is ambiguity at its
finest for example when I worked on
boyhood with Richard Linklater there's
there was a large component of I have no
other word for it than what I've read
about in jazz the beauty of jazz music
is that there's no plan there's a plan
there's an architecture let's say let's
take something obvious like my favorite
things right John Coltrane's my favorite
things if people know one jazz thinks
often they'll know that one and he takes
this famous song no no no no no no right
and and they all start riffing on it you
know the musicians start riffing on it
and they find a new melody inside it and
it changes and it changes and then
mysteriously comes back around again and
spontaneity mixed with discipline and
intelligence it evolves into something
you cannot plan that is more
sophisticated and more interesting than
something the intellectual mind can plan
when you're really being creative at
your best you've used your discipline to
open up your subconscious you know Bob
Dylan is a great quote where he says um
you know I didn't write that man you
know when you and somebody sing you
don't have an idea for a song Mama's in
the basement mixing up medicine I'm on
the pavement tell me that's not like oh
I got an idea for a song let me write
the subterranean homesick blues right it
doesn't it doesn't work like that it it
works like you got something to say and
then something it's an antenna that goes
up right
and you some people I think mistakenly
think somebody's channeling God or
something like that in a way you're
channeling yourself and you're
channeling your own questions and your
own seeking and your own which is deeply
connected to your own we all have it you
know we we all have an essence a center
that is us we have it that they were
born and when you can access it then you
can access the subconscious and and
that's gonna be more powerful and more
true than anything your intellectual
mind has to say you know I want to write
a screenplay and I'm gonna write an
important screenplay about the election
process in America because I have
something to say about I think it's
fraudulent I think it's stupid and I'm
gonna write a screenplay about a woman
you know and you start working on it and
you have this idea about what the result
of the screenplay is supposed to be and
what it's kind of like saying I want to
win the game you can't win the game by
trying to win the game you have to play
the game and you have to play the game
well and you have to play a
moment-by-moment well and oftentimes if
you're right action right thought right
motivation right work ethic you'll win
the game but you can't try to win the
game you're jumping over hurdles it's
like my kids sometimes well they know
it's wrong to lie but they don't know
why so because they don't know why it's
wrong to lie they still think that if
they can get away with it then it might
not be wrong right and if you know why
you're not soso lie then you know that
doesn't matter whether you get away with
it or not I find creativity at its best
is not working towards a result yes I
have when I do we do the before trilogy
some
time's the I've did these three films
before sunrise before sunset and before
midnight
and we often jam ourselves into position
meaning oh we've gotten these
people to agree to finance the movie
we've got to start on August 1st and we
only have 20 pages like that that
happens so yeah we do have an agenda
that to finish this thing but Richard
Linklater's patience is incredible I
mean we started before sunrise with a
scene in the script that just said scene
63 the best scene in the movie then I go
to 64 like I mean it literally it was
said the best seen the movie Jesse and
Celine take their relationship to a new
level we haven't discovered yet and then
it moved on and we started the movie not
knowing what that is and it oftentimes
people will come up to me on the street
and say to me hey I loved before service
that scene where they pretend to call
each other while there and talk to their
best friend that's the scene where
pretending to be on the phone with each
other and you know that scene happened
in a very mysterious way Julie had an
idea and then Rick had an idea and then
I said an idea and all of a sudden the
scene happened I'm in a couple days
before and Rick has an unbelievable
patience meter I mean it comes from
playing baseball that you know you wait
for the right pitch you know and you you
don't swing it until you have to and
it's it creates an energy where Rick
doesn't think he knows the right answer
you